- Yo, guys, Insta-pose.
- Oh I don't know about that.
- That was bad.
(electronic music)
- We're gonna be trying on
Fashion Nova stuff today.
I'm super excited.
I know about Fashion Nova
because of the Internet.
I've seen it on Instagram,
and I'm excited they have a men's line.
- I don't really know
much about Fashion Nova,
but I like style, so I'm
down to give it a shot.
If it works for Cardi B, it'll
work for me, I'm guessing.
- The only accounts I follow
on Instagram are dog accounts.
I have no idea what Fashion Nova is.
This seems like as good a way
to buy clothes as any I guess.
(jaunty music)
- Whoa.
- Oh, okay.
We do, we really look like a boy band.
- The color, I've never
worn anything this pink.
- I don't think so.
- Step out of your comfort zone.
- I know, and I want to, I want to!
I'm not huge on graphic tees,
I like my tees mostly just black--
- Solid color.
- White, gray.
The fit's pretty good though,
it feels a little loose.
I bet if I washed it, it'll fit perfectly.
- I like this jacket though.
- No, yes, the jacket is nice.
I love the way the pants fit.
When I was putting them on,
they felt a little stiff.
But then once I got them
actually on my body,
I was like oh, they have
more give than I thought.
- 50 bucks for a pair of pants
is definitely more expensive
than H&M, but it's about the same
as a Uniqlo or something like that.
The first look, I could--
- I dig it.
This is definitely something like...
I would just go out and about out.
- I've never looked
like this before, ever.
- We were just saying his
regular style is more like Dad.
- You guys don't have to say that.
As long as it's not dead-beat Dad.
(camera shutter clicking)
- [Joshua] We got some more
clothes to try on, let's do it.
- Okay.
- Think we look good!
- You look like a hipster rock star.
- That's actually the coolest
this body will let me look.
- I really like this, but it
also totally freaks me out,
because it's a lot going on.
I'd never wear stuff like this.
- I think on your skin tone,
a lot of colors are gonna look great.
- I like it, it fits good.
- See, you have a little
chest hair going too.
Getting a little Miami Vice-ish.
- And I also like how
lightweight the shirt is.
- I like these pants, these
are very much airport pants.
- It looks like you were in
the airport going to Hawaii.
- Yes, that's exactly what I'm doing.
I think you also would look
good with the jacket over.
I love this on you, really I do.
- So size-wise, I feel really
good about sizes as a medium.
So far so good.
- Same, I think this shirt fits great.
I like the flowiness of it, it's fun.
(camera shutter clicking)
- [Joshua] To the next, last outfit.
- [Garrett] Yep.
- [Joshua] Let's do it.
Let's do this.
- Okay.
- Ooh, yeah, what?
- I like this.
- You look good!
- I like this jacket.
- I am upset that I did not get one.
- I would love to see you rocking this
on a regular basis too.
I tried on this new pair of pants,
similar to the other ones.
They're kinda like khaki-type material.
So all the pants seem to
be about in the $50 range.
- Which makes sense.
- $110 for a full outfit--
- For a full look.
And honestly, that's about right.
- Yeah, and this you could
wear with anything else,
this you could wear with
anything else, anything else.
The thing I like about these clothes
is that they give you
options to be really stylish
without having to try hard whatsoever.
- I'm so surprised--
- Yeah.
- That I was able to
just put this together,
just from a random box.
I got three decent outfits.
- Yeah.
- I'll be real, about all this stuff,
I feel like immediately,
you're photo shoot ready.
It started to make since, I
get why it's so big on Insta.
- It does look really good
on you guys, I dig it.
Am I Cardi B now?
- You're so close.
- Oh good!
(camera shutter clicking)
(electronic music)